so
keep
[Music]
push push
don't lose your grip
push
don't use your grip move your body there
you go
oh there you go let go then
you lost it again you lost it again
don't lose your grip down
oh push good
loosen it again body boom there you go
again here we go
low body
go see my body
now my arm body
body
fine then you have to use your body
[Music]
oh
not important
i don't need the grip oh the grip's not
going to save me
body
body here
good
[Music]
good hand in face two more hand in face
good switch
you absorb
[Music]
okay so i added a deviation
it doesn't mean he goes out of his body
okay
so i other deviation is still in his
body
so a deviation still in his body
deviation in his body
deviation in his body deviation
his body deviation in his body
okay
it's going to deviate in your body
and push push deviate in body
that's right oh get that elbow inside
your other room
hit that elbow inside your shoulder line
okay
[Music]
your body bow if you need to hey
outside your shoulder get your elbow in
case
bring it up more get your other hand
who's shot over the dart
there you go one more
okay let's see so i'm gonna deviate but
you're gonna keep connecting
going to deviate are you going to keep
there you go
oh good
oh scoop up that mine's too close
oh there you go
oh keep it all in here
dva in there better
deviate too close out
yes nope out keep it inside this
shoulder line your elbow don't let your
elbow go here
hey
[Music]
so uh i deviate and he's got his body
into the technique that your uh q
projection is going to be much easier
with smaller movements so try to get out
of this thing
he just pushed in a deviate bomb and
you'll get it
okay and then secondly you'll have your
strike hit okay so
once once he has that uh touch right
there
that that's your contact point so it's
really a two-hand throw
but usually you're unconscious of this
and you're just here
it's very much like raphael hansi goes
to garage you would do the two hands
so you stick a honda he's got it
you can get the two-hand throw oh that's
it
two hands
okay let's go
no i don't want you to go anymore like
him
you gotta guard your face
aim in the center
don't fight his grip you want him to
touch you
you want him to touch you there you go
you want him to touch you dude put the
hat in his face
go bow
shoot them on walk right
oh that looks soft
come on that's it
yes protect yourself good
good come on don't let the guy in by
having a mushy arm
oh elbow in distance you're too close
distant
don't touch him he touches you then you
throw what he touches
put your hand in his face
and his face then he touches it
then you throw it good
two more hand in his face
deviate
stay connected don't throw him away from
you throw into him
[Music]
keep
so
firstly demon he killed him
don't go dead tristan
[Music]
just in your arm tristan
let's go finish it
boom feet under you elbow shoulder
down oh outside your room again
come on
don't let go
hey
good come on
you're all dead now going back to the
dead
alive alive a lot
brains alive oh alive
tighten it up tighten it up stick your
leg up
there you go let's go
good in down good
good
now do it without the emotional content
let's go same movement
try it again now that's a different
movement
down
here we go i hear that oh
live good alive at the bottom don't get
all mushy
live alive good alive yes that's it
two more live live live
don't turn it up dude
[Music]
there you go